暑い。
と、いえばみんなはどうしますか?
そう。
暑さから逃げる、というわけで
北海道にやってまいりましたー!（歓喜）
（拍手）
1人です
あの笑えないくらいに暑いんですよ日本が
もう地域によっては30度40度いってるっということで
もうさすがに耐え切れませんということで
えーわたくし今回北海道に来ております
ちょっと別件でやることがあって来たんで
あのUUUMのマネージャーさんと一緒に2人で（意味深）来てるんですけども
あのまず北海道に来た瞬間の一言目いいですか
マジで涼しいんですよもう
というわけでまあちょっとゆるっとした動画最近あんま撮ってなかったんで
まあ夏休みゆるっと
まあ1人北海道の旅
１泊２日なんですけども
のんびりしていこうと思います
ちなみに隣の部屋なんですけど隣がUUUMのマネージャーさん（男性）です
（走るはじめん）
なんか静岡とかね東京とかもうね
北海道来ることなんてないかんね
高級ホテルっぽいんだよ
いぎまじょう
え、マジみんなに体感させたい
この涼しさ
すーずしー
ﾋﾟｯﾎﾟｳww　ﾋﾟｯﾎﾟｳww　（横断歩道の音）
ｴ､ﾊｼﾞﾒｻﾝﾀﾞ！
あ、こんにちは
ってか涼しくないすか北海道
ｴ､ﾅｷｿｳﾅｷｿｳ（無視）
涼しすぎてやばい
ｳﾜｰ
俺は北海道にいない人間だからね
bean sprout！（もやし！）bean sprout！（もやし！）
やっぱレアなんだろうなー俺がいるのが
とりあえず何がともあれ僕動画の編集があるんで
その北海道っぽいお店行って
北海道っｐ　あれここかな？
多分ここだね
北菓楼って書いてある
わー確かにめっちゃオレンジ色いなこれ撮っていいんかな
とりあえずちょっとあの僕 もう帰って動画の編集が残ってるんで
（上記の図をご参照ください）
うっしゃー狩ったー
公園とかあったら嬉しいなって感じですね
ほらもう空が秋
めっちゃきれい
いや待ってやばいなー夏の北海道良すぎるなー
東京とかさ暑い場所に住んでる人は
絶対行ったほうがいいです
夏の北海道
俺ほんと今北海道に住もうか迷ってるぐらいね気に入ってる今
（はじめん移動中）
やべぇ公園ないな
公園ってかこれさえ食えれば良いんですけど
これ食って編集がんばります
予言師登場
一人できたからさあ寂しかったんだ
今ビアガーデンやってるんすよ
ビアガーデンﾝﾝﾝﾝﾝ！？
え、いーないーな
（イメージ映像をお楽しみください）　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　札幌出てきたばっかなんすよ
あ、そーなの！
４月から出てきて
めっちゃくちゃ大きいんすよ
えーやばってか人多いなぁ
（予言）
（予言的中）
めっちゃ涼しいっすね北海道（リベンジ）
やばいシュークリーム食えない
（おじさん見てないフリ）
結構いろんな人が声かけてくれて嬉しいです
じゃあホテル帰ります
ｽｲﾏｾｰﾝ　ｼﾂﾚｲｼﾏｰｽ
じゃあ味噌ラーメンのチャーシュー抜きでーす
ｽﾞﾙｽﾞﾙｯ
うん　うまい
（ガチャ爆死）
ｯｼｬｱｰ（歓喜）
ﾊｯﾊｱｧｯ↑ﾌｧｱｯ↑ｱｱｯ↑
俺浮いてんなー
これ多分あれだな
北海道で有名な建物です
俺見たことあるもんこれだって
これなんかよく見るヤツな気がするんすよね
なんかどこで見たかは分からないんですけど
北海道といえば札幌といえばコレみたいなやつだったと思います
へーかっこいいなーでも入ろうかなー
（迷い中）
（本心）
はい、というわけでパズドラやってたらお昼過ぎになってたんで
もう結構帰りの飛行機が近いので
札幌といえば何があるかちょっと分かんないんですけど
ちょっと調べますか
はい、わー眩しい
はい、というわけでちょっと調べたんですけど
なんだっけ、ﾕﾘｶﾞﾊﾗ公園みたいな公園がね
なんか調べたらめっちゃ綺麗だったんで
そこに行こうと思います
すげえ黄色い
ﾕﾘｶﾞﾊﾗ公園までお願いします
あ、ﾔｯﾍﾞ　ｱｯｱｯｱｯ
札幌ｺｴｰ
このﾕﾘｶﾞｵｶ公園（改名）って所がね
何かネットで見たときすごい綺麗だったんで
ちょっと見ていこうか
ﾌｳｯﾌｰｳ↑
あ、人が少ない
このﾕﾘｶﾞｵｶ公園は少し変わった羊を見れることで有名です
また、豊かな自然と植物も見どころです
また噴水には自動追尾システムが搭載されており　　　　　　最新システムの一片を見れることも魅力の１つです
なおここまで適当
あーキレイキレイ
北海道感が出てますね
あっ羊（フラグ）
（フラグ回収）
あ！なんか公園っぽいところが出てきた
北海道満喫してる感出てきましたねー
うわっ北海道って感じが出てるー（乙女）
無事間に合いましたマジで結構ギリギリ
制作　N○K放送
帰ってきましたー
あー日本の気候は
エンディング
ｯｳｩ
ｽｲﾏｾﾝ.......
うわびっくりした
いいですよ
ｽｲﾏｾﾝ（２回目）
ありがとうございます